[MUSIC PLAYING]
[DOOR OPENING]
ANDREW BROGDON: A mediated
ad unit can request ads
from not just AdMob but
a list of ad networks,
and it used to be that each
ad unit had its own list.
That meant that if you had 100
ad units across a dozen apps,
you also had 100
mediation stacks, which
is difficult to maintain.
But with the rollout
of the new AdMob
interface comes
Mediation Groups.
Instead of configuring a
similar list over and over
for a bunch of ad units,
you can do it just once
and have multiple ad
units reference it.
In addition, there's now
support for multiple line
items for a single network.
So if you're mediating a network
that supports price floors,
you can target them several
times with different values
and have a chance to get
the most valuable ad.
So that's Mediation Groups.
And if you've updated to the
new AdMob user interface,
you can start using
them right now.